[Music]
you live in London and so you have you
have daughters and when you're and and
they say in London you come to America
you work are you under pressure because
when I travel my kids expect something
back I usually find something in the in
the air I work like H like oh yeah I get
them each like underarm deodorant yeah
or a lozenge
yeah all right just take the paper thing
that's on the seat that your head goes
on one of those I'm like there you go
kids that's a big treat where I just
came well I wish I could anything nice
do I have to really because I travel a
lot and it's awful and I'm desperate for
their love and with him not to resent me
so I laughed on my left London Eye I
bought them two hamsters to sort of
replace me and I'm Matt and that really
worked but usually I think that's sad it
works all of our emotional needs were
met it's very sad but know you have a
store here called American Girl oh I
know America we don't have that in the
UK and Cory you don't I'm so glad we
don't that place is evil and so when I
come over here my my I buy her American
doll tout and but one time she she asked
me would I take her American Girl doll
and get it today ears pierced you can go
to an American Girl store yes you can
and you can get your doll groomed it's
vile I mean it shouldn't be allowed it
makes you feel like a terrible terrible
person
but I was just desperate for her love so
I was like of course and so I I took the
doll and I happened to be with my friend
Tom at the time he's gay gentleman and
we found ourselves in the in the queue
to get the American girls dolls of ears
pierced and we realized that we did look
like a couple who couldn't have children
possibly
we're using the doll as a sort of
substitute baby and the alter that maybe
I wasn't aware that my husband was gay
and I we driver you know because that is
tableau this whole story and I think it
cost $30 or something you know what you
can go I'll tell you what kills the pain
of feeling ashamed when you go to
American Girl Plus you can drink there
you can't not yes you can there's a
restaurant where you can take your doll
I went there we actually shot it for the
show I went there and I thought totally
wasted with my doll I think we have a
picture here of it I got so wasted on on
white wine with my doll and and then I
felt amazing and I noticed a lot of moms
around me all these moms there the
daughters are off hanging around playing
with the dolls and the moms are just
throwing back bottle after bottle after
bottle and they couldn't be happier
of course yeah of course they're
drinking heavily yeah yeah America and
there's a little bottle for the girl one
box for Mom yeah wine for the girl
you